in the lobby of Ramsey solutions bill
and Angie are with us hey guys how are
you doing great Dave how are you I am
better than I deserve welcome welcome
where you guys live we are from Cadiz
Kentucky Oh fun and you're here to do
your debt-free screen
yes we are how much have you paid off we
have paid off sixty-eight thousand two
hundred thirty one dollars and ninety
two cents I love it and how long did
that take sixty three months good for
you and your range of income during that
time started about fifty five thousand
and up to about sixty six thousand good
man that's incredible so what kind of
debt was the sixty eight thousand that
was medical loans and student loans and
a car loan and our house as well you
paid off your house we paid off our
house couldn't where people how's that
feel it feels fantastic that's so cool
it's so freakin rare I mean that's just
unbelievable Wow way to go you guys
excellent excellent job that's fun so
what puts you on this journey sixty
three months ago well I don't know if
you remember we had a really big ice
storm in Western Kentucky in 2009 and I
remember it was during that storm the
power had been out for about ten days we
got the call from Bill's boss saying the
company is downsizing and I need you to
step down from your position as Regional
Sales Manager so I don't have to fire
somebody else
ouch and I got scared cuz that was a
stay-at-home mom sure and didn't know
what to do so I started clipping coupons
and following the coupon mom well one
day I was flipping through the channels
and she was on your show yeah yeah and
so I stopped to watch your show and I
was hooked that led to us getting the
Total Money Makeover
and then eventually taking FPU very cool
good job you guys very fun and so five
years know you've been trudging through
this you got everything knocked out and
then you reached over knocked out the
house or maybe step six
yes very well done so what is your
advice to people that are maybe they
just heard they're losing their job
maybe and here you said five years of
the side of that story and it's like
woke me up man I mean it changed
everything it changed the whole
trajectory of your lives how old are you
two I'm 45 I'm 44
okay and so you you know you're with you
sitting here I'm looking at paid-for
house people right here yes I mean tell
people how you do that what is the
secrets to getting out of that the big
secret is following the budget you learn
how to do the budget and financial piece
of university and follow that budget and
work together on that every month we
still sit down every month and go over
our budget numbers and work together and
doing the budget and doing it together
is the biggest key to it yeah very cool
good David
I made a lot of sandwiches in the past
all right bill I have my least favorite
sandwich on the planet I'll tell you
it's a tuna fish sandwich I can't stand
tuna fish because when we were broke
Sharon made tuna fish sandwiches and
when I smell tuna fish right now my net
worth goes down I can't stand it
it's broke people food man people say
it's healthy but it's broke people food
as far as I'm concerned what's your
what's your least favorite sandwich you
hope you never eat again after this that
I never have to eat again would be
chicken salad no right there what oh
yeah
all right that's the same kind of
they're not cousins yeah yeah right
there together some but I still love my
Bologna hey man we were laughing the
other night I think once you're once
you're redneck you just love Bologna
manna bologna sandwich with a big ol
slice of red onion couple ripe tomatoes
some mustard and mayonnaise on some
white bread life is good my mouth
watering right now that's almost better
than filet mignon on me I'll just tell
you where you go that's cool you guys I
love it I'm so proud of you
congratulations and your kids are with
you right yes and their names and ages
are we have Annabelle is nine and we
have Carrie is 6 now Annabelle and
Carrie have they been involved in this
five-year trend they have been involved
in this five year Trek towards the end
when we had just the house to pay off we
decided to get them a little more
involved that they're old enough to
start to understand and we borrowed some
of their Legos and we built a Lego tower
sitting right next to the television
okay
and each Lego represented a house
payment and each month we would take off
Legos for however much we paid off some
months it was one Lego some months it
was several Legos so they got to watch
and participate
as we finished paying off the house and
baby step 6 I hope you got like Tim
time-lapse photography no we just think
collapsing down over time we didn't
think that man oh did you get pictures
at least at some point I hope not not of
the Lego tower no oh you have to rebuild
it just so you can take a picture act
like a nought but the big part to their
reward for helping in this journey was
that once the Lego tower was gone the
house is paid off we all get to go to
Disney World
alright so when's the trip it's
Christmas time this year I love it good
for you guys that's cool well they want
to tear that tower down tear that tower
down we want to see Mickey yeah this is
it and there's a there's a carrot at the
end of this stick man that's awesome
good for you guys very very well done
alright we're gonna give you a copy of
Chris Hogan's retire inspired book
signed by him number one bestseller and
that's the next chapter in your book is
now to become very wealthy you don't
have any payments and become extremely
generous outrageously generous and Chris
will show you how to do that and as the
next stage here now that you're
debt-free you just keep the story going
man
because Annabelle and carries life has
been changed their family tree has been
changed I'm looking at 44 year olds with
a paid for house the numbers where
you'll be at 75 are astronomical I mean
it's astronomical I'm so proud of y'all
very very well done all right bill and
Angie Annabelle and Carey $68,000 paid
off in 63 months fifty five to sixty six
thousand dollar a year income on our way
to Disney at Christmas count it down
let's there a debt free scream three two
one
well
well done well done man that is bad Ulis
very well done I love it I love it I
love it
hey that's fun stuff hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common